country music fans get ready to dust off
your cowboy boots because
the 2020 canadian country music awards
just announced this year's list of
performers and let me tell you september
27th
right here on global is going to be a
wild night i mean dallas smith
to neil towns dean brodie brett kissel
and the reclaws are just some of the
canadians that take the stage
yes but that's not all also joining them
from nashville
are sam hunt breeland kane brown and for
the first time ever
three-time grammy award-winning
superstar
tim mcgraw canada throughout my career
has always been a
huge part of my career even early on i
started coming to canada early on
before i had a hit record i told my
agent i said book me in canada
in january february the coldest part
because
you know directly helps they'll come see
me just to get out
you said your purpose is to bring people
together through music
i mean what does it mean for you to
bring joy to people at a time like this
well i feel lucky for sure to be able to
do this for a living
i think that art art in general all are
but
i'm fond of music but all art
finds a way in the toughest times to
raise its hand and
let's say that i'm here for you say that
i'll be your
i'll be your soft place to land i'll be
your
pillow you cry on i'll be your catharsis
and i'll be all those things for you and
despite the global health crisis 2020
shaping up to be a massive year for the
singer
tim just released his 16th studio album
here on earth
is a very powerful title and it made me
think about what is happening right now
how would you describe
2020 well the worst year ever
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's the song right there you know but
there's been a lot of great things
that's happened
in my family you know my daughter
graduated from stanford in 2020 my
youngest daughter high school in 2020
so it's good stuff but it's stuff but
they're missing out on on some of the
great moments in life that those
accomplishments
pretend you know and so we try to make
it as well
as good as we can but we've also had
great moments as a family because we're
forced to you know you're forced to
quarantine you're forced to be together
[Music]
what was the priority to you before all
of this happened
is not a priority anymore
oh gosh um that's a tough one
um because i only have a few priorities
anyway what are those
eat sleep where's my wife
i guess just to make sure to just
be in contact with your kids more i mean
that's really
the main thing is just really contact
each other more and
tell each other you love them more and
those kind of things some some of the
things you take for granted because you
think
we'll always all be here and uh you know
life will always be the same and we'll
just roll along and have a great time
but it's not like that
but there are times when when uh they
need to know
and you need to know that that
foundation's there